love is a lot easier
than hating I've said I don't regret not
one step of my journey and I had someone
say to me
you should regret it those were horrible
things that happened to you I'm curious
about how you work through the pain of
those abusive situations that you were
in embracing love it was either be angry
judgmental all of those things those
those things are not going to heal me
to take responsibility for being the
human that I am
and knowing that going forward each and
every second of my journey
I'm learning every single day I'm not
running a hundred obviously but I learn
every single day love is a lot easier
than hating